how do you know what business you should
start it's one of the most common
questions I get asked and again I got
asked it in a different form from one of
our YouTube viewers Ronald who wrote
insane how do you know what you really
wanted how did you learn how you could
help people
how did you sort out all your ideas
feelings and find the one that was most
important to you so thanks for the
question Ronald it's a great question to
really spend time thinking about because
too many entrepreneurs start just trying
to make money and if your goal and
business is just to make money you're
gonna fail the guys who started business
just trying to make money almost never
do you have to start a business around
something that you're deeply passionate
about and something that you know really
helps people how did I find what I like
to do what I love to do the story like
the towel is after I sold my first
business I was asked a lot of speaking
people wanted me to come and help their
group of entrepreneurs and I remember
doing one of my first events was with
the YMCA and they promoted this event I
promoted and I spent a couple of weeks
preparing and I was gonna help change
the lives of these people who are coming
out to this event and I remember walking
through the building all excited ready
to go with my presentation going up the
elevators going into the room big room
full of chairs and everything stopped
for me for a second because I walked
into that room and there were only three
people who showed up
and I took a deep breath you know cuz
that sucked to do all that promotion and
preparation for only three people to
show up but I did my presentation and I
helped those three people that day help
change their lives change how they think
and while most people might have thought
of that as a failure I loved it
there was something about it I just
loved to do when I knew I had to go and
do it again and even if I wasn't making
money doing it I have to find a way to
keep doing it I take a job on just so I
can keep doing it again and that's how
you know if you're on the right path if
you look at any famous entrepreneur and
how they got started at the core is a
deep love for what they do and they had
failure after failure after failure in
terms of business making it a success
but they kept going because they loved
it so you've got to find that thing that
you love to do that you would do even if
you weren't making money it makes you
feel good it makes you want to help
people you makes me want to do it again
that's how you know you're on the right
path it's got to be a combination of
something that you love doing that also
helps people in a very meaningful way if
you can combine that you're gonna be
unstoppable don't just jump into an idea
because you think you can make a lot of
money out of it you're gonna end up
quitting in a couple months losing a lot
of money on it losing a lot of time
being frustrated and angry it's gotta be
something around an idea that you deeply
believe in and that you know helps
people it's a great question thank you
for asking for it I hope you guys
watching it will take it into
consideration when you're planning your
business for those of you watching if
you did like it this video please give
it a thumbs up
I love seeing those coming it makes me
want to do more and if you have a
question for your own business
feel free leave it in the comment
section below I always read those I love
seeing that come in so thank you and
I'll see you on the next episode